hello everyone and welcome to the second
game we'll be showing from round three
of this year's Norway chest it is
Fabiano Corona versus sadio antari the
first game that we've shown was Magnus
versus Hikaru at that beautiful Kings
Gambit um that was an Armageddon game if
you haven't seen it do check it out it's
my previous video uh Hikaru vs Magnus in
the king's Gambit that is simply a
must-see uh but this one uh it's uh not
easy for tarias he lost his previous two
matches uh Fabi he won his previous two
matches of course Fabi would like to
continue winning because one of his
victories is against the Magnus Carlsen
In classical time format so he if he
does really well he's uh definitely on a
collision course with uh with a victory
uh in the tournament uh and tari would
definitely like at least draw the
classical if if not win it and then
grabs a couple more points so let's see
what he can do against the former World
Church Championship Challenger uh Fabi
has the white pieces and he opens with
D4 and I'm not exaggerating with the
title This truly is like surgeon so on
Knight to F6 we have Pawn to C4 upon the
E6 and Knight to F3 we have D5
transposing into the Queen's Gambit
declined C capress on d5e captures and
knights the C3 so the exchange variation
nothing new here upon the C6 and I'm
Bishop to G5 still the most common move
here we have Queen to C2 uh G6 and now
Bishop to G5 with Bishop D7 not allowing
the the PIN to exist with E3 and now
Bishop to F5 nicely developing both of
the bishop study doesn't wanna
uh get get his Bishop um uh locked in or
go for some sort of a B6 Bishop to B7 C5
maneuver so Bishop to F5 as it comes
with an attack on the Queen Bishop to D3
and he just trades off the light Square
Bishops captures captures and he castles
the safety uh Fabi could also Castle to
safety but he has a very different idea
of how he wants to steer this game
Bishop captures on F6 uh Bishop captures
and now okay he gave up his dark Square
Bishop but uh he removed the defender of
the H5 square and he plays Ponte H4 he
just goes for the black king he wants to
play H5 open up the black King's
position and go for some sort of a
checkmating attack if possible which
means that he might even be considering
a queen side castles uh so here uh and
interestingly H4 is not that often
played here the usual idea is Pawn to B
for but okay Fabi goes for Pawn to H4
Knight to A6 incredibly rare move but
the queen is in D3 so you might even be
considering Knight to B4 and here are
queen side castles was played it was uh
played some uh 13 years ago but here we
have Ponte H5 by Fabi and it is now as
of move 13 that we have a completely new
game so okay Pawn to C5 uh it's a very
uh you know definitely a principled idea
uh you uh reply to the attack on the
flank by attacking your opponent in the
center you want to open up the white
King's position and just attack him as
he is still on E1 and here you would
expect something like Castle's Queen
side but nope Fabi just goes sorry Fabi
just goes Rook to D1 he keeps the king
and E1 which means that he's uh probably
considering something like King to F1
maybe even King to G1 uh all depends on
what uh tari plays and now uh you could
play C counters on D4 but after Knight
captures you're never opening up the
center and the white king is perfectly
safe I need one so instead Knight the B4
goes after the queen queen back to E2
and now Rook the E8 nicely aligning The
Rook with the king and queen but just
King to F1 and the King will be very
safe there and you might even think but
what about C4 can't we just bring the
Knight to D3 yeah actually no just
Knight to E1 uh guards the D3 square and
next you will kick away the Knight with
A3 and then just bring the Knight back
so nothing really happening there so
instead Rook to see it by tari uh and
now H captors and G6 Fabi just opens up
the black king H captors and pawn to G3
now here Fabi saying that he's
interested in moving the king to G2 and
then maybe even doubling up Rooks on the
H file we have King to G7 Now The Rook
can also enter the H file King to G2 and
now C captures on D4 we have Knight
captures on D4
uh and now you don't have to worry about
Bishop captures The Rook is also
covering that uh Knight the C6 uh here
uh of course star is saying my knight on
B4 is just being weird it's doing
nothing and your knight on D4 is truly a
spectacular piece you know a mighty
steed controlling all of these wonderful
squares so just Knight the C6 thought he
wants to trade his bad Knight for five
he's a great night Queen to F3 and now
Rook to E5 now uh Knight captures on D4
is the move that you kind of should play
point is that after captures and
captures it seems like there's no good
way to defend the D5 Pawn but you can
defend it with active play something
like Rook to C6 and if Knight captures
then just Rook to D6 and everything is
perfectly fine Knight T3 for example you
will cap run D4 white good capture on B7
you will play Rook to E7 and you have
sufficient activity for that one Pawn
that you have um uh given up so okay
that's one way to do it uh in the game
Rook the E5 was played by Aryan and now
Knight Dita E2 we have Rook death 5
going after fabi's Queen on F3 just
Knights the F4 and now how do you
continue G5 although it looks nice
doesn't really do anything because okay
the Knight cannot move but you can play
Rook captures on D5 The Rook on F5 is
hanging so it's you know just Rook
captures now Knight to H5 check you also
go after the bishop so nothing uh fun
Happening Here knife captures on F6 uh
this is being threatened like this like
this like this Rook to h8 being
threatened You're Gonna Lose the queen
so this would be resigns for tari so
instead after Knight to F4 Bishop
captures on C3 he eliminates one of the
attackers of the D5 Pawn B campus and
now Queen to G5 so getting those uh
heavy pieces in front of a fabi's king
but doesn't matter just Queen to E2
preparing to go after that D5 Pawn uh
Queen to E7 and now we have Knight
captures and D5 why did tari play Queen
D7 why did he allow Knight captures on
D5 uh the queen and Rook from G5 uh were
nicely guarding that D5 Pawn well he
either calculated well or he
miscalculated let's see what happens
Knight captures on D5 we have Queen to
E6 now preparing to win material here
and the point is if you go back which is
kind of the idea then Queen the E4 check
and you will now ruin White's Pawn
structure because white has to play F3
if you try to block this it's not really
gonna work if you move the king to G1
the knights the E5 comes then Knight to
F3 check and this is not fun so instead
Ponte E4 by Fabi and now just Rook to E8
so of course The Rook cannot be captured
the queen on E2 is hanging so just Rook
H the E1 and now we have Queen back to
C8 now again you cannot capture because
Rook captures on E2 would happen but
Queen to C8 having that in mind
completely blunders the game for Aryan
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for Fabi while I give you a couple
of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on never listening to
what I say as I say the weirdest of
things and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
he captures an F5 Fabi captures The Rook
he sacrifices the queen and uh of course
this is the first move you thought of
but the the the truth of The Possession
lies in the very next move so this is
the one you had to see so Rook captures
I need you of course you have to capture
the queen there's nothing better and now
comes the uh the real idea and that is
Pawn to F6 with the check and now
there's really nothing for uh Aryan to
do here the problem is whatever you do
there's just no continuing this game it
doesn't really matter where you move
your king uh whatever you play King to
f8 was played Rook captures on E2 now he
has two Rooks for the queen without uh
Aryan having any control play uh Queen
to F5 was played kind of putting
pressure on the Knight here and on the
F6 Pawn but just Pawn to C4 in absolute
Cold Blood this is uh I mean you you
really feel bad playing this with the
black pieces now the pawn is nicely
defending the Knight the Knight is
defending the pawn here and it's it's
merely a matter of rookie one and The
Rook d8 Checkmate there's no actual way
for black to stop this so of course he
will try Knights the E5 going for this
one last idea uh but it doesn't matter
Fabi will allow this as a courtesy Rook
dte1 was played Queen to F3 check King
to G1 and he was in this position on
move 34 that ariantari resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here there's no Rook captures on E5 is
coming next if you move the knight uh
Rook d8 Checkmate is coming so this is
resigns one's the night at least the
board is going to be a knight and two
Rooks for the queen and of course that
is completely unplayable and the Knight
is there to State the F6 Pawn is there
to stay so the black king will also get
checkmated it's not uh I mean it's not
even it's not even close to something
that you would maybe try to play uh so
yeah that's why I I said Like a Surgeon
Fabi uh surgically you know execute it's
executed this entire game uh absolutely
unbelievable tari played the brilliant
chess pretty much every move was an
engine moved by both of them but then at
some point uh that he made a couple of
sub-optimal moves and Fabi just punished
that um uh you know
in the maximum possible way
uh so yeah really incredible stuff for
those of you who do not wish your
experience to be ruined and would not
like to know what happened in the other
games you should end the video now
because I will now discuss what happened
in the other games even though I might
cover a few more so let's check out what
happened uh okay so first let's check
out what happened
um in the other games of course we've
seen uh gookish has defeated they went
into uh Armageddon lost to alireza
alireza defeated noderbeck in the
classical time section I'm hoping to
cover this game next Fabiano defeat
Atari we've seen in the classical
section uh uh Wesley so lost to Anish
giri also in Armageddon and the Magnus
Carlsen has defeated Hikaru Nakamura
also in Armageddon if you haven't seen
it check out my previous video Kings
gambling between Magnus and Hikaru
doesn't get any better better than that
so that's the that's the stuff and this
is the standings after round three Fabi
leading the tournament with seven and a
half points as one should when he did
when defeating Magnus Carlsen In
classical time format second place out
it is with six points with five uh
Kimura gookers with four and a half and
he's given another vocabulous with four
uh Wesley so with three and a half
magnets Carlson in eighth place with
three points in ninth place with two and
a half points in the ariantari in last
place with uh only one point so there we
have it we're gonna I believe I'm going
to check out the game between alireza
and Notre back next and then we're gonna
discuss you know some other things like
the the shifting power in the in the
world top 20 in the live ratings and
maybe some other fun stuff maybe we
check out some photos who knows uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it Fabi you know when he does it
well he truly is Like a Surgeon I would
like to thank uh Bunty Revolution
reptiles YouTube Miha Zakaria establish
Espana and Brandon fukuda for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day